foreign
I was told to remind everybody that if
when you speak if you could turn your
microphone on that would be great I'm
going to call the subcommittee work
session to order of 10 4 22. today we
have two bills that we're going to work
through HB 426 which will take first
relative to shorterland septic systems
then SB 257 enabling municipalities to
incorporate sewage Disposal Systems as
part of the storm water utility this is
a work session it's not a hearing if we
need clarification and there's someone
in the audience that could clarify or
add to something I'm told we can have
that but we're not taking testimony
today
uh I want to thank representative Spang
she passed out everyone here should have
it
um a brief
dissertation on Shoreland septic systems
and I'm going to recognize her she's
going to speak briefly to her report
here which I have given and Will Go On
actually huh okay we'll see what we can
do here
okay this bill came right out of a
two-year Shoreline septic system study
commission that had about 20 people on
it very representative of municipalities
septic designers
environmentalists
the Realtors uh and uh so we had a good
understanding of how it was any
solutions we came up with would affect
each one of those parties
and it was approved by the 20-member
commission by everyone there but the
Realtors and Des abstained the problem
is that there are
a lot of there's a lot of pollution that
is occurring because of
underperforming septic systems in the
Shoreland Zone it's very hard to find
which ones it is without infringing upon
private property rights
we decided to try to
inch away a wind inch toward how to make
that
determination the first thing that would
be obvious is this older ones before
1967's septic system did not have to be
approved by Des
so they're kind of wild cards after that
then Des was looking at uh at permitting
them so we knew that the one that the
ones that were most likely to be in
Failure were those that did not have
state permits
and they could now be
um
up to 50 years old so you can imagine if
they've been up to 50 years old and
perhaps never pumped never inspected the
houses that they are serving may have
doubled and tripled in terms of the
intensity of their usage so that looked
like a good place to start
so we began to then look at how we could
get a handle on those again without
infringing upon private property owners
and there have been several uh efforts
put forward by lakes groups to do some
heavy educational work of the property
owners
um getting volunteers out there to talk
to them and
then contact the members on that the
people who own Shoreland properties on
impaired
water bodies that are particularly have
blooms or cyanobacteria Etc
those turned out to be really successful
in some instances like 13 out of 15 of
the septic systems that were or 20
septic systems that were examined
with landowner permission termed out to
be in failure
and then that then the volunteer group
was able to get some State funding to
help those property owners
ameliorate their systems in some cases
like on babusik Lake it was tremendously
successful and they were able to
eliminate the severe cyanobacteria
blooms that had happened so we know that
that is going to work but that is
the only other time that the state can
have any intervention
is when a property exchanges hands and
already we say that you have to have an
evaluation of the site to say yes the
site can have a septic system that will
serve the kind of property that you are
the house that you're thinking of
putting up there but that's as far as it
goes if there is a septic system there
and the property is exchanging hands
there's no way to say whether that
septic system is indeed in failure and
is going to or underperforming and is
going to be continue
to affect the water quality under its
new ownership
so it seemed that in addition to having
an evaluation of the site to see if the
land is capable of holding a septic
system we should also be requiring that
the septic system itself should be
evaluated
now this I think there was some concern
about who's going to pay for this and
that you know there's a lot of
a lot of negotiation around around costs
and expenses and who pays what when a
property exchanges hands um there's a
property owner the seller pay for things
like this does the buyer pay for things
like this does the realtor help to pay
for the things like this all of that can
be worked out even on an individual
basis just as long as the state is
um the result of it would not
necessarily say that the prop it would
block the property exchange it would
just but the report would go to the
local code enforcement officer and to
Des so Des could see where these
problems are
it was also seen as being a real Boon to
the property buyer so he wasn't buying a
pig in a poke he wasn't buying a septic
system where the the seller said see
there's nothing squishy on about it's
fine it's fine and then they find
themselves having to uh
to build to rebuild their septic system
so it was really uh
a protective thing for the property
buyer and a big plus for the State of
New Hampshire in terms of finding out
which septic systems might be a problem
now
it's certainly not all of them it's only
the ones that are exchanging hands and
it's only the ones within a certain
distance to a water body but it's a
start and it's one that the commission
felt was very achievable
so that's where we are that is how the
bill came about
thank you representative what I'd like
to do is since there's only five of us
go around the table for comments
representative glottling do you would
you like to speak on this uh Bill uh I
would and just say that uh in our town
uh one of the reasons septics have come
into uh
discussion is that we are dealing with
uh what people are perceiving as
problems with short-term rentals and
concern that houses that are sometimes
shall we say overpopulated
maybe stressing the septic systems and
uh so we're really uh
cognizant of the problems because
although we have a portion of of the
lake front covered by an actual sewer
system and I'm lucky enough to be one of
those we have a lot of other portions of
the lake that do not have a sewer system
for them and uh I as you will remember
from my short from my uh Perkins
Pondville uh before that that uh
uh
sewer system went in around the pond
there there were latrines and there were
there were all kinds of really really
really old ineffective uh systems in
place and this Pond now it that it is a
Haven for short-term rentals but
fortunately everybody there has to be on
the sewer but uh had we not done that it
would probably be overwhelming uh so so
I would just say from our town it's uh
the short-term rentals have kind of
highlighted the fact that we have many
uh old systems
and not not really a good mechanism for
taking care of them
yeah I'm just gonna I talked to our
Town manager of the and the
um
Kyle Fox director of Public Works about
this in
um one of the things he said that they
like to keep it local all the time and
the reason was and I know you brought up
Baboosic Lake
um right now they are at sixteen hundred
dollars per year with a state average
for sewers is
about 590.
Merrimack we pay 357. when they do this
I'd like to see the local people make
that decision whether that's going to
happen
um in Amherst on the Busick Lake they
decided that
that wasn't going to be the town was
going to pay for it and if they the
local group wanted to do that they did
and they did get together and they got
together and they decided to do that
solar system
um but they brought it up the the cost
upon it with them on them themselves so
I still always say let the let the towns
decide in this and let them let them
make the decision whether they're going
representative Healy I think we're
talking about whether the septic systems
need evaluation yes I know okay all
right I wasn't sure if you were crossing
over to the next no when she was talking
about I was just covering up when she
was saying it would be it was with music
Lake that they did yes there was but it
was constantly obvious
they're
just here to visit my first subcommittee
here
okay
it was suggested I remind those that are
speaking when you're done
button off so that you won't be taking
okay yeah I just I was wondering if we
have ever we must have had commissions
on how to handle failed septic systems
in the past
I or have we
um but I would like to see more of a
study committee done uh since this is a
problem like everywhere it's it's it's
been a problem endemic and and I
acknowledge the problem of failed septic
systems is a big problem and
um I really appreciate that the
education worked as representative Spang
was pointing out uh how well it worked
to address it directly to the homeowners
um
so I mean I I would like to see that and
that's all I have to say about that
representative Spang you wanted to
comment again uh yes
in terms of the um
the
we of course we've already had a
two-year commission looking into this
program and this bill came out of that
two-year commission and it was we tried
every angle that we could in terms of
how to look at it and also the science
behind how a septic system works and
alternative Innovative new ways of doing
it so we really looked over that pretty
carefully
in terms of keeping it local
um
the low the municipalities are not now
enabled by State Statute to do anything
about this
the towns of Meredith
um I think one of the other towns had
tried to bring about some set a local
controls over septic systems and they
were told that they did not have the
statutory ability to do it so then they
went uh digging deep into their
ordinances and Interstate statutes to
find an alternative way of skirting
around that problem and they they're
trying to work with their building codes
or CFOs
but none of that is secure enough to put
that forward as an approach that other
municipalities could use so essentially
one of the problems that
brought about this commission was that
municipalities do not have the ability
to do this on their own they need some
thank you representative my take on this
is
I think it's a buyer beware I think that
I sort of go along with the remarks of
the New Hampshire Board of Realtors
Association of Realtors
in this particular area the 200 feet or
whether it's 200 250 the assessment's
done but on all the purchase and sale
agreements the buyer has given the right
to do more inspections more reviews
nobody's saying they can't ask to do it
so instead of mandating it I think the
ability is there I'm not one for
mandating this and I had mentioned
during our original discussions I'm
concerned that this could turn into what
they have in Massachusetts title five I
think the ability to test the system I
agree that yeah it's a big expense if
suddenly it fails but the buyer can do
this inspection he can do the evaluation
and a lot of my buyers because this is
the field I'm in they do have it
evaluated to make sure they're not going
to have this sudden drastic problem they
didn't need a law to say you have to
they just went and did it and they
absorbed the cost so we're not worried
about the cost because they said we'll
absorb it for the large expenditure of
buying a new home
so I'm not personally in favor of this
bill
is anyone on the committee subcommittee
wish to say anything further
add one thing which is that in our town
at least many uh sales were taking place
and inspections of any kind were simply
ignored and uh we also have a number of
out of out of town out of state buyers
who really don't have a big commitment
to
you know what they're doing so that's
just another aspect of where our concern
thank you it was brought to my attention
that what we're supposed to do was the
subcommittee we have two choices on
motions to recommend for future
legislation or not recommend for future
legislation
if none of the subcommittee members have
anything else entertain a motion from
someone either to recommend or not
if I of course
um I think that the problem is you know
this in in the Bible beware thing
um really resonates with me you know
you're going to buy you're going to buy
anything without checking whether it's
going to cost you a fortune to keep that
car on the road or whatever
um
but in those instances you're the only
one who's going to be affected by
whether you buy an inferior product
in this instance if you buy an inferior
product and you decide that you don't
want to put in the money or you don't
even want to know with your septic
system is polluting your Lake it's not
just you it's everybody who lives along
that Lake who is paying the price for
your having decided to turn a blind eye
to this there's nothing that says that
if you buy a house with a bad septic
system that anyone is going to make you
fix it
so
um it's not just you know you're being
you're whether you're going to have to
be putting in a lot of money to fix this
it's whether what the impact of your
negligence is going to be on everybody
else who lives along the lake
you could draw parallel with having your
car inspected
um Inspire beware if you buy a car that
won't pass inspection but why do we have
a state program where everybody's car is
inspected it's because it affects
everybody if your car is an unsafe car
it's the same situation here
where you can decide that as a buyer you
don't care whether your septic system is
failing
but everybody else around that lake is
thank you representative I'm still
waiting on a motion Mr chair
um in
speak I know I'm not on the subcommittee
but my understanding was that all
members of the committee were invited to
attend and participate in these but we
just couldn't vote
so that's I have to believe what the
chair uh chair ranzulo put in the email
but what I wanted to clarify a little
bit is what the interim study uh
what it means
the bill is off the table this bill is
gone
so the motion to recommend for future
legislation or not isn't necessarily
this bill it could be a small part of
this bill it could be to refine the
definition of what a failed system
septic system is it could be to just
tweak uh stuff and it's not anything
that we have to totally decide today but
it could be we recommend for future
legislation because the statute isn't
clear blah blah blah blah blah in some
area so I just wanted to clarify when
you say not recommended for future
legislation you're talking about the
issue of Shoreland septic systems not
this particular bill because this
particular bill is interim studied which
means this bill is dead we would be
recommending yes or no on any future
legislation related to Shoreland septic
systems just wanted to clarify that
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion that we recommend this for um for
further legislation what I'm hearing um
from two of our members is that there's
a desire not to take this approach but
to make it more local
um and and that would seem to me to be
an exploration of how to uh
enable municipalities to develop their
own regulations relative to failing
septic systems that are polluting their
local lakes and it seems to me that
something that it was brought forward
very pointedly uh by the town of
Meredith that was trying very hard to
protect its water supply
but it seems to be that there are some
and I'm very big on local local control
also uh so since that was the program
the problem that's was clearly
identified
by the commission and seems to have some
resonate resonance with the member of
this committee that we recommend that
this be brought forward for future
legislation to solve the problem from
that direction thank you representative
do we have a second
elephant
hearing none will take a vote
representative Spang
yes this is a vote to recommend for
future legislation with your motion yeah
representative gottling
and myself the subcommittee chair I vote
no so that motion failed
put a motion into not recommend for
future legislation
we have a motion by representative Healy
not to recommend seconded by
hearing none representative Healy
yes
yes representative how are you Boley
yeah
representative Spang no
representative gottlene
and myself representative harb yes
so three to two we will recommend to the
full committee at executive session not
recommended for future legislation thank
you so that concludes our discussion on
moving on
SB 257 enabling municipalities to
incorporate sewage Disposal Systems as
since we started the last time with
representative Spang for comment I think
I'll start this time with representative
Healy on my left representative Healy do
you want to comment on this bill SB 257.
I'll comment a little bit on this
um we and Merrimack just went through uh
hiring an ms4 engineer
um for this uh specific system of our
systems now which is actually separate
so we don't really have to do too much
um it it's quite an expense to the towns
um and again the towns made the decision
to make this uh to hire this ms4
Engineers so I'm I'm
going forward with this I would say the
same thing that I would like rather that
the the towns make a decision or
anything on any of all of this stuff
um it ends up being at the engineering
anything and then this engineer makes
anywhere from seventy five thousand to a
hundred thousand dollars a year
um it was a ballot question also so I
want to keep it that way
thank you representative representative
I I agree with the representative Healy
um I
looked at this uh quite a bit I did some
background work I guess there's a study
happening right now and the uh Dover
area to look at it's like a pilot
program
um
that they're doing uh on their own to
study this so I'm curious to see
what's going to happen with that I think
the bill needs some work I'd like to see
Municipal
um I'm wondering if it's really more
suited and the municipal uh committee
than ours but it is uh it's it's fine if
Town towns want to do it but I certainly
don't want to mandate it um
for
uh for everybody
um that's it thanks thank you
and we can jump over you and go to
um I think that there is a problem with
this bill because it has
it's a little bit difficult to get your
arms around in terms of there are a
couple of or several components to it
one is it
means that you have to understand
how your utility works like how our
storm water utility works the stormwater
utility basically says that whoever is
responsible for creating the problem
should have some responsibility for
solving that problem at some level
um
not there is not one single municipality
to date that has adopted this it would
require the support of the whole
municipality it wouldn't be something
where the state would be imposing this
on any municipality it is strictly by a
local choice
um the second thing is what is the
problem that it solves I think that
perhaps it was Mr deers or Carolyn
Russell who told us about situations
where there was kind of a mini Community
where they were all in failure
and what do you do about that are you
going to make every single one of those
do an individual
upgrade or replacement of their septic
system or can it be done collectively as
a neighborhood and if that neighborhood
can plug into a municipal system with
all these other neighborhoods where this
is a problem then the cost gets
dispersed
um and it becomes the
the septics problem isn't just a problem
of each individual property owner but it
becomes something that the community as
a whole has decided that they want to do
something for their water body
um as a whole and they want to make it
part of the whole tax base instead of it
being something that an individual would
be paying now
the third component is and I think that
this really
raise some eyebrows is the problem that
we have in the Great Bay Estuary where
we have to do something at more than an
individual septic system level to try to
clean up the bay and EPA is breathing
down our necks to come up with some
solution to these individual septic
systems that are collectively causing a
big problem and I think that having this
tool in place
would help to reassure EPA that we're on
the road to doing this and once again I
would like to emphasize the word tool
it's not a mandate by the state it's a
tool that a municipality can take to
deal with multiple septic system
failures on individual properties so I
think that um
given that there is no mandate involved
that is just enabling municipalities to
take one approach whether they like it
or then I think that we should
um get this moving along thank you
thank you representative representative
Gottlieb
well I'm looking at
who's supported and who did not in at
our hearing and Des definitely supported
this bill and as in our other Bill the
Realtors opposed and the Dover City
Council supported and you know we talk
about letting towns Take the Lead but if
they need permission to take the lead uh
we're sort of talking out of both sides
and we're not really being
straightforward about what we really
thank you representative
I agree with some of the committee
subcommittee members that there there is
a problem with the nitrogen and the
systems but is this really the solution
I also seem to agree
um that if we put government back
locally and the local people decide they
wish it maybe that's more appropriate
than a mandate for everyone
so I'm sort of betwixting between I
don't think the bill as representative
Smith says we're not really dealing with
the bill that was presented I don't
think that solves the problem but I do
think that it is an issue that could use
uh future study and and work
so I I likely would support a
recommendation for future legislation so
that the topic can be worked on and
so I'll and anything else from the
committee members
so I'll entertain a motion from someone
to recommend or not recommend for future
legislation
and just just to clarify so we would be
recommending the I the idea of the bill
for future recommendations not the bills
not the bill itself okay so basically
the concept that's inside the concept
okay I'm interpreting representative
Smith correctly
concept would live on but it needs work
and we could support the concept of
local control
oh okay but for future legislation not
this bill
okay I I would make that recommendation
so I have a motion
by representative Harvey bolia to
recommend for future legislation
any discussion on that motion
uh just what what specifically are we
recommending
my understanding would be we're
recommending future
legislation that would relate to the
I say it right a nitrogen level and
septic systems and
local control
okay I guess I'm not opposed to that
yeah
so we don't kill the idea we keep the
idea moving with work
so that's the motion the second any more
discussion on it okay so I'll call a
roll
representative Harvey bolia yes
representative Healy yes
representative Spang yeah
and my self-representative harb I vote
Yes
so that will go forward to the entire
committee at the executive session on
this bill SB 257 recommended for future
legislation
and I believe that concludes what we're
here for today and I thank you all for
coming down on a sunny day hopefully it
gets a little warmer and we'll see you
at the um unless anybody has anything
else to say we'll see you at the exact
session that's already scheduled
so I call this uh session closed thank
you